[Música] há
mais de 30 anos, quando eu tinha 10
anos, passei duas semanas na casa
dos meus avós e durante as
férias de verão e eles moravam nesta
casinha no topo de uma colina no interior da Bélgica que
eles não tinham  muitas
coisas eles não tinham um sofá eles
não tinham uma TV eles tinham uma mesa e um
par de cadeiras e à noite nós
jogamos cartas eu ainda me lembro que no
quarto deles havia um
guarda-roupa marrom escuro enorme e  em cima a
minha avó guardava estes dois vasos uma
noite perguntei-lhe pelos vasos e
ela desceu as escadas e deixou-me
subir para que eu pudesse ver mais de perto
e enquanto olhava os vasos ela
disse-me que estes usavam  pertencer à
mãe dela e que agora eles eram tudo o que ela
tinha para se lembrar dela por eu disse que
eles são lindos anos depois antes de ela
falecer ela disse ao meu pai
explicitamente que ela queria que eu ficasse com
os vasos lá o valor é quase
nada além de  para mim são tesouros e
estou muito  emocional sobre eles nos últimos
20 anos tenho estudado essas
emoções as emoções que temos em
relação a objetos projetados e fascinados
por eles e trabalho com designers e
estudantes de design tentando explorar como
podemos projetar emoções positivas como
podemos projetar produtos que  as pessoas
gostam muito de usar
e nós temos um curso e chama-se
design para a emoção e na primeira
aula pedi aos alunos que trouxessem
algo que eles apreciam um dos seus
tesouros e os produtos que eles
trazem são muitas vezes produtos simples e
simples mas sempre com  belas
histórias como a bolsa colorida que
lembra a estudante internacional de seus
valores culturais ou este pequenino bloco de
Lego que representa uma bela
memória de infância e todos nós temos
esses objetos que apreciamos aposto que você
também os tem talvez em algum lugar em uma caixa
ou em  uma gaveta, mas nós as guardamos
mesmo que não funcionem mais
porque fazem parte da nossa
herança pessoal agora eu sei que  pode soar um pouco
romântico falar sobre objetos emocionais
porque a realidade é que estes são
apenas muito poucos a grande maioria dos
produtos em que gastamos nosso dinheiro
não somos tão emocionais sobre não os
valorizamos muitas vezes não realmente  até
notá-los com certeza eu posso ter um sentimento positivo em
relação a um objeto que parece
legal como esta caixinha de leite bonitinha
que eu peguei no aeroporto ou você pode
ficar irritado quando os produtos não funcionam
do jeito que disparam, mas isso
resume muito bem  gosto de todas as emoções que temos em
relação aos produtos de consumo e
quando pergunto às pessoas me falam sobre as emoções
que você tem em relação aos produtos
que possui, muitas vezes começam a rir ou
até um pouco irritados, dizem que não sou
emocional com os produtos.  estou
emocionado com meus filhos sobre minha
família sobre meus amigos e com certeza muito
emocionado sobre muitas coisas, mas
não tanto sobre produtos ou assim parece
porque a realidade é que
na verdade estamos muito emocionados com profissionais  dutos
sobre todos os produtos
se este iceberg representa todas as
emoções que temos em relação aos
produtos de consumo, então a ponta do iceberg são
as emoções que temos em relação aos
objetos queridos e o resto do
Berk abaixo da superfície são todas as
emoções que temos em relação aos  todas as
outras coisas e estamos tão emotivos
sobre todas essas outras coisas quanto você está em
relação aos nossos objetos queridos a única
diferença é que muitas vezes não estamos
tão conscientes dessas emoções que não estamos
cientes dessas emoções porque são
micro emoções  e vou dar um exemplo
este é o meu relógio e tem um
contador de passos então o bracinho me diz como
estou indo bem nos meus passos diários quando o
comprei fiquei fascinado com a
tecnologia e então comecei a usá-lo
e descobri que também mede o
meu ciclo de sono e fiquei espantado com
isso e senti esperança porque pensei
ooh, isso vai me ajudar a me tornar mais
saudável e depois de uma semana mais ou menos, é
claro que fiquei envergonhado porque  os dados me disseram o
quão doente eu realmente era
e não acabou aí eu tenho muito mais
emoções positivas e negativas em relação
ao objeto e essas são micro emoções,
então elas evaporam assim que as têm,
nós as esquecemos, mas elas são
emoções reais e assim que você começar a
se conscientizar disso você vai se
surpreender sabe que no sábado passado eu fiquei em casa
porque eu tinha que me preparar para essa palestra
e tirei uma foto do primeiro
produto que eu toquei que foi meu
travesseiro e então eu  tirei fotos de todos os
outros objetos que toquei naquele dia
e no final do dia acabei
com mais de 400 fotos e descobrimos
que cada objeto, mesmo os mais
simples como uma caneta, evoca pelo menos 10
emoções positivas ou negativas diferentes
enquanto estamos usando, então se eu
toquei 400 produtos e cada um
deles evoca 10 emoções que somam
mais de 4.000 emoções durante o dia
e isso são apenas os produtos que eu
toquei e nem contei os  aqueles
que acabei de ver, por isso estamos muito emocionados
com os produtos as pequenas emoções são
apenas ondulações na superfície da nossa
consciência por isso evaporam assim
que as temos, mas no momento em que
as temos quando as experimentamos
elas desaparecem  influencia nossos sentimentos nossa culpa
nossa ação e nossa expressão e você
pode até ver se você observar bem de
perto você pode vê-lo em suas mãos
quando estiver usando produtos porque
emoções diferentes estimulam
diferentes tipos de qualidades de
interações
e uma vez que você se torna consciente  disso, se você
se conscientizar de todas essas pequenas emoções
que você tem constantemente quando está
usando produtos, você ficará surpreso ao ver
quão nova instalação é; descobrimos que
existem pelo menos 25 emoções positivas diferentes
que você pode experimentar
enquanto você está usando um produto e para mim
que representa como um repertório de
oportunidades é como uma tela de design
porque cada um deles pode ser projetado
para e é isso que fazemos com nossos
alunos e eu darei um exemplo de
um trabalho de projeto estudantil projetado para
crianças que estão hospitalizadas para
tratamento de câncer e por causa do tratamento
elas têm que ficar isoladas para evitar o
risco de contaminação então elas estão
literalmente atrás de uma parede de vidro há um
vidro  parede entre eles e o resto
do mundo eles não podem tocar outras pessoas
e isso leva de quatro dias a quatro
meses, então você pode imaginar como
essa situação é emocional para os cuidadores e
as crianças, então você fez uma
análise muito completa de tudo o que está acontecendo
acontecendo nesta situação e ele olhou
para todas as emoções que as crianças
têm e ele escolheu uma dessas emoções
e ele projetou para isso e isso foi
diversão e é isso que ele projeta
para o meu projeto de graduação no DIA Delft Eu
desenvolvi um jogo que  permite que
crianças isoladas em hospitais de trabalho brinquem com os
seus
medos chama-se Kinect e é um jogo que
podem jogar nas janelas entre os seus
quartos e os corredores pelo pente  Ao incorporar as
formas ambíguas de diferentes maneiras, você
pode jogar diferentes tipos de jogos para que
possa jogar jogos existentes, como jogo da velha,
mas também pode construir seu próprio
mundo de fantasia para testar conectar nossos lugares no
departamento de oncologia de um hospital infantil holandês
e  isso é o que acontece
eu amo este design porque é tão
simples é apenas um par de ímãs e
ao mesmo tempo é tão profundo
porque ele pegou a barreira na
parede de vidro e a transformou em seu jogo
play scape um contexto para o jogo social e
muito divertido agora eu sei que
às vezes as pessoas me dizem você sabe
sim Peter isso é tudo legal mas você está
projetando para a ponta do iceberg
você está projetando aqueles produtos
que podemos apreciar e todas as outras
coisas as coisas  que carregamos e
não nos importamos muito com isso, minha
resposta para isso é que na verdade não é o
designer que determina se o
produto será apreciado, é a
pessoa que o compra e quem é o dono do produto.  t e
aqui está um paradoxo, acredito que,
enquanto continuarmos dizendo a nós mesmos que não somos
tão emocionais com os produtos,
seremos vítimas muito fáceis
daqueles que tentam manipular nossas emoções
para comprar coisas que realmente não
precisamos  e nos aproveitamos contra
essa manipulação desconfiando de nossas
emoções dizemos a nós mesmos não
ouça sua emoção seja racional porque
sabemos que as emoções podem ser
manipuladas e proponho um
caminho diferente eu diria não confie em suas
emoções abrace-as  conhecê-los
torne-se um especialista em suas próprias emoções
porque se você for um especialista das
emoções em relação aos seus produtos ninguém
será capaz de manipulá-lo e
é assim que você se habilita a começar a
valorizar objetos e eu tenho três dicas
três dicas sobre como  chegar ao topo
do iceberg três dicas sobre como abraçar
suas emoções em relação aos produtos começar
com o primeiro foco nas atividades novamente
um projeto de estudante chama-se uni
keys é don  e por Yanina e seu desafio
foi preciso projetar algo que
permita e estimule crianças com
deficiência física a brincar com
crianças que não possuem
deficiência física e isso pode ser um grande
desafio às vezes
a essência do jogo é que cada
deficiência representa um superpoder
por exemplo, se você é surdo, você pode usar a
linguagem de sinais, o que significa que você pode se
comunicar a longas distâncias, então
neste jogo as crianças com deficiência
são os super-heróis as outras
crianças podem se tornar super-heróis também elas
têm que desenvolver seus próprios superpoderes para que
todos  as crianças juntas elas geram
e inventam superpoderes e
se divertem muito enquanto fazem isso o que eu
gosto nesse design é que a Janina
disse que eu não vou desenhar algo
que as pessoas precisem comprar então não há nenhum
produto brilhante e sofisticado envolvido é  apenas uma
folha de papel com algumas instruções
e você usa as coisas que já
tem em sua casa é a atividade que
conta  s e psicólogos provaram
que não são as coisas que possuímos que
influenciam nossa felicidade, é o que
fazemos, são as atividades com as quais nos envolvemos
com as coisas, então da próxima vez que você
comprar um produto, não se concentre muito
no  emoções que você tem em relação ao objeto
tente imaginar todas as emoções que você
terá no contexto da atividade de
usar o produto porque se você puder fazer
isso o produto se torna um recipiente para
essas experiências dica número dois concentre-se
na sua própria identidade
novamente um aluno  projeto Santiago
desenvolveu este cofrinho eletrônico e
ele usa seu smartphone então o que ele
faz ajuda você a gerenciar suas economias e
ele começa mas você insere uma meta para que você
possa dizer por exemplo eu quero economizar para
comprar sapatos de caminhada e o cofrinho
ajuda  você para monitorar o quão bem você está
indo e quando você chegar lá para
poder comprar esses sapatos e ao mesmo
tempo em alguns momentos inesperados ele
imprimirá pequenas etiquetas e as etiquetas têm
perguntas  perguntas sobre o que
você está economizando e as perguntas são
coisas como como esses sapatos que
você vai comprar ajudam você a desenvolver quais
talentos você precisa usar e
desenvolver como eles permitirão que você
contribua com outras pessoas  algo
além de você como isso irá ajudá-
lo a aprofundar seus relacionamentos que
você tem com as pessoas que você ama
como isso aumentará sua vitalidade
seu bem-estar mental e físico
então é bom ter emoções positivas
em si mas a beleza  das emoções é
que também há pontos de entrada para
entender nossos próprios valores, então sempre que
você tiver uma emoção em relação a um produto, isso
significa que ele toca em um de seus
valores, para que possamos usá-lo para aprender sobre
quem somos, quem são nossos valores e
realmente  para crescer nossa identidade e se
fizermos isso o produto se torna um repetitivo
desses valores e você está evoluindo a
dica de identidade número três foque em ser
virtuoso e este é o projeto final do
estudante de design t  que vou mostrar que é uma
cadeira de rodas para crianças e este não é
o design da Ava esta é uma
cadeira de rodas convencional e o que Ava fez foi
medir as emoções que as crianças
experimentaram em relação às suas cadeiras de rodas
e descobriu que elas evocavam muitas
emoções diferentes positivas e negativas
mas tinha uma parte da cadeira de rodas
que evoca uma emoção negativa muito forte
que ela havia antecipado
porque é uma parte que as crianças nem
mesmo são as alças uma das virtudes
dessas crianças é a autonomia ser
independente e ter essas
alças para fora  das suas costas mostram o
contrário, eles mostraram que eu sou dependente,
então aqui está o redesenho que Ava fez, como
você pode ver, mudou de muitas maneiras diferentes,
mas uma das coisas que
ela fez foi tirar o chapéu, ela tirou as
alças e  ela colocou uma barra e quando
a criança não está sendo empurrada a barra
desliza para baixo atrás do assento e
tornou-se irreconhecível como uma barra de empurrar, por
isso celebra a virtude de um  utonomy
dessas crianças este produto este dispositivo
é chamado de saco de saco este não é um
dos meus projetos de alunos é um
produto existente e o que ele faz é ser usado
por guardas florestais para tirar sacolas plásticas
das árvores e por que eu amo esse design é
porque as pessoas veem isso e ficam
inspiradas e começam a formar pequenos
grupos de voluntários para voltarem a roubar
no fim de semana, então elas são inspiradas por
este produto para fazer algo de bom e
todos nós temos forças e virtudes de caráter
sendo gratos sabedoria bondade honestidade
e nós  podemos usar nossas emoções como radares para
identificar aqueles produtos que ressoam
com nossas próprias forças de caráter e
que nos permitem pegar o que é bom
dentro de nós e colocá-lo no mundo exterior
acredito que esses podem ser os
produtos que aprendemos a valorizar  antes da
minha palestra tenho mais uma história para
contar sobre a cadeira de rodas é uma
anedota usei muito este exemplo e
este é um dos primeiros projectos que
fiz quando estava a começar  ng para ensinar eu
uso em minhas palestras para os alunos e um
dia após a palestra um dos
alunos veio até mim e era Bart
e ele está no meio da foto
e Bart está em uma cadeira de rodas e
ele me disse que eu sei  a cadeira de rodas e eu
pensei que eles tinham isso é possível porque
temos o protótipo em exibição em nosso
prédio e então ele disse que eu conhecia
essa cadeira de rodas anos antes de me tornar um
estudante de design, então ele teve que explicar isso
para mim
e me contou a história  que quando Ava
desenhou sua cadeira de rodas ela construiu um
protótipo e ela foi para uma
escola primária para testá-lo com crianças que era
sua escola e ele era uma dessas
crianças e ele ainda se lembrava disso
quando essa senhora entrou com esta
cadeira de rodas e disse a eles que  ela
desenhou aquela cadeira de rodas ele ficou tão
inspirado que naquele momento ele decidiu que
eu também quero me tornar um designer acho
que é um belo exemplo de alguém que
abraçou suas emoções em relação ao
objeto projetado então eu gostaria de convidar vocês  para fazer
o mesmo da próxima vez que for
comprar um produto abrace sua emoção para
que o que quer que você compre se
torne um de seus objetos queridos e
talvez até parte de sua
herança pessoal obrigado